[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be doing
something a little bit different
now hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry has
quite a fine reputation among the
wizarding community
it's produced some of the most
impressive witches and wizards
good and bad and for centuries it has
served the wizarding world
but how has hogwarts served for such a
long time
why that can be credited to the school's
backbone
its professors without the professors of
the wizarding world
young witches and wizards would be
entirely left to their own
devices there would be a lot less order
far more stressed out parents and a lot
more homeschooling
hogwarts gives students a place to be
themselves interact with other children
and truly tune in to their magical
abilities however
with all of that said professors aren't
perfect
they're people just like the rest of us
and they make mistakes in their personal
and professional lives on that note
today's video will discuss
five mistakes made by five different
hogwarts professors
in harry potter the list will range from
trivial mistakes
to big no-nos without further ado
let's get started number one queerness
quirrell
before the school year started in the
philosopher's stone
coronus quirrell who taught defense
against the dark arts to harry in first
year
went jet setting off into the world
however what no one knew
at least for most of the school year was
that quirrell was possessed by voldemort
the queerness quirrell was an english
half-blood wizard born sometime in the
1960s
when he was of age he began attending
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry
at which point he was sorted into
ravenclaw house
it wasn't very long after he himself had
graduated that he was able to secure a
job
as muggle studies professor at hogwarts
in the year 1990
kroll took a year-long sabbatical he
told his peers that the sabbatical was
an opportunity for him to gain
first-hand experience in the field where
in reality
his objective was to find lord voldemort
exceedingly curious about what had
happened to the dark lord who tyrannized
the wizarding world
for years on end quirrell always wanted
to be noticed and acknowledged
and he felt that if he was the one to
track down lord voldemort
then he could finally earn the attention
that he longed for
however after finally tracking voldemort
down quirrell was completely taken
advantage of by voldemort quirrell's
biggest mistake here
was finding voldemort in the first place
foolishly thinking that he would be a
match for him
voldemort puts it nicely a wizard young
foolish and gullible wandered across my
path in the forest i had made my home
oh he seemed the very chance i'd been
dreaming of
2. slughorn horrus slughorn is a british
wizard with a long history at hogwarts
school
he taught for many years serving as head
of southern house
as well as potions master slughorn left
hogwarts for 15 years
four reasons i'll get into in a minute
but did eventually return
where he picked up where he left off and
began teaching potions again
however the reason that slughorn left
hogwarts in the first place
directly relates to his big mistake
telling tom riddle about horcruxes in
the half blood prince when dumbledore is
showing harry
slughorn's memories an interaction
between slughorn and a young tom riddle
is revealed
at first they only had part of the
memory an incomplete
tampered version but later the truth
comes out
i was in the library the other night in
the restricted section
and i read something rather odd about a
bit of rare magic
it's called as i understand it a i beg
your pardon
a horcrux i came across the term while
reading
and i didn't fully understand it i'm not
sure what you're reading tom
but this is very dark stuff very dark
indeed
which is why i came to you a horcrux is
an object in which a person has
concealed part of their soul
slughorn's mistake in this scene is
about as big of a mistake as one could
make
as he effectively though inadvertently
set tom on his path of creating his most
dangerous weapon
his horcruxes 3. dumbledore
this big mistake pertains to albus
dumbledore powerful wizard
hogwarts professor and most notably
hogwarts headmaster
dumbledore is often painted as this
all-knowing
omniscient type but as it turns out
he too makes mistakes just like the rest
of us
and his big mistake occurred in the 1994
school year when the school year began
like with any other year
all of the students gathered to the
great hall the beginning of term
this was an opportunity for dumbledore
and any professors
to address the student body at the
beginning of the year
announcing anything pertaining to the
upcoming school year
and it was 1994 that once again a new
defense against the dark arts teacher
took over
famed death eater captor alistair madai
moody
moody was a good guy a famous dark
wizard captor
but there was something off about this
moody that no one seemed to really
notice
may i introduce our new defense against
the dark arts teacher
said dumbledore brightly into the
silence professor moody
but here's the thing it wasn't actually
moody before term
started moody was captured by bharti
crouch jr
a british pureblood wizard and death
eater
crouch jr trapped moody in his own
magical trunk
and then impersonated him the apologies
potion
for nearly an entire term successfully
teaching
defense against the dark arts in
questionable fashion
but how did the ever wise and
all-knowing dumbledore
miss this how could he let a death eater
imposter
infiltrate the school in effect
dumbledore's biggest mistake
was simply not noticing and it's a hard
one to let slide
particularly as dumbledore was meant to
be a good friend of moody
4. snape zephyrus snape was a half-blood
wizard who taught multiple subjects at
hogwarts
he started off as potions master where
he taught for 15 years
then assumed the professor for defense
against the dark arts role
in 1996 he would also later become
headmaster of the school
before his untimely death snape was
certainly a peculiar fellow
and one of the prominent grey characters
in the series
he was also extremely calculated and
intelligent
tricking voldemort as a double agent for
a considerable amount of time
so what mistake you might be wondering
now did severus snape
make well it all relates to the fabled
prophecy
this is the same prophecy that prompted
voldemort to travel to the potter
residence
in an attempt to kill harry but what
prompted voldemort's actions
why snape of course you see while
trelloni relayed the prophecy to
dumbledore
and the hogs head in snape was there as
well and he heard
nearly the whole thing snape a death
eater at the time
then immediately relayed this
information to voldemort
inadvertently resulting in the death of
his love interest
lily potter i'd say this was a pretty
big mistake
on snape's part 5. hagrid hagrid aka
rubius hagrid
is a half-giant half-wizard that
attended hogwarts in his younger years
though he did not graduate due to events
pertaining to tom riddle
and the chamber of secrets however after
being kicked out of the school
he did assume the role of keeper of keys
and grounds
working under someone else at first and
he also eventually ended up
teaching becoming professor for the care
of magical creatures
so what mistake did the lovable half
giant make
well this one's going to sound
considerably less impactful than the
others
but in essence hagrid's made mistakes
around carelessness with students and
magical creatures
in his very first lesson there was an
incident involving draco malfoy and a
hippogriff
that ended up turning into a total mess
hagrid also bred
blast and his screws and openly exposed
students to them
which is certainly questionable given
how dangerous they are
hagrid is a great man but sometimes his
judgment
was questionable and that's it for this
video
honorable mentions go out to lockhart
for letting cornish
pixies loose and lupin for forgetting to
take his wolfsbane potion
if you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel
until next time it does not do to dwell
on dreams
and forget to live